imagine you were on the run from
machines and you had a choice you could
be chased by machine a which was
programmed by a hundred humans but it
had a fixed behavior and couldn't learn
new things from its experience or a
machine B it was programmed by one
person with nothing but the ability to
learn rapidly to achieve its goals of
finding you which would you choose you
could say the field of artificial
intelligence began by fearing machine a
which followed human instructions during
the second half of the 20th century it
became clear that non learning machines
were not as intelligent as we'd hoped
them to be there was no unified
definition even among AI researchers in
the last decade or so the modern field
of AI has shifted to this learning first
view of intelligence how good you are at
learning it views learning as the core
mechanism or engine behind what we call
intelligent action where learning is the
search for a behavior which achieves a
goal and behavior is what you do and how
you react to the environment it's also
why machine be the one that learns from
experience is so scary it would be
constantly adapting to your patterns of
behavior and could learn behaviors
outside the scope of your understanding
this machine learning paradigm
represents a bottom-up view of
intelligence inspired by how nature
solves problems via learning and when we
look closely at the natural world we can
identify three distinct layers of
learning let's start with the first
layer evolutionary learning now is there
a difference between life and
intelligent life if we were looking for
intelligence in space what would we look
for imagine for example we found a
simple slime like mold on another planet
similar to earth researchers have shown
that molds can sense and grow towards
food sources in ways that solve complex
problems for example they exposed slime
molds to food locations which mirrored
the Tokyo railway station locations to
see how efficiently they would grow
towards food what they found was the
mould solved the problem as well as
humans did by growing an optimal system
of lines between the stations or food
you can't beat this track
so mold exhibits a distributed form of
intelligence which is part of the very
fabric of life so let's just focus on
life itself a key feature of what we
call life is that which can survive and
replicate in the environment how it
achieves this goal is the mark of
intelligence imagine we found a single
celled life form such as this bacterium
when we observe bacteria we find that
they have a swimming behavior which
falls into two obvious states random
swimming where it changes directions
randomly and straight swim bacteria are
looking for sugars so you'll find they
swim in some random direction and store
a memory of the smell at that position
and then it moves forward slightly and
compares the smell at that point to its
memory and if the smell is getting
stronger it swims straight if instead
it's getting weaker it swims in a random
direction and this process repeats as if
it's playing a game of you're getting
warmer or colder by itself using smell
climbing towards the strongest smell
where the food likely is if you think
you can do better give it a try close
your eyes and imagine like the bacterium
you were trying to find someone cooking
food your natural strategy will be the
poke your nose around in different
directions until you feel an increase in
some smell once you find the direction
of a sin you'll walk a straight pathway
towards the food by walking uphill in
the smell space with all the power of
your brain you can't do better than
bacteria given the same information this
example is important because it shows a
pattern behavior behind life
continuously try random things and keep
doing what works well a process of
improvement or learning we call
evolution it's a slow learning process
that happens over generations for
evolution to take place living things
must contain a recipe for how to copy
themselves DNA is a long molecule which
stores information for how to make the
parts of a life form and it's written in
an alphabet of four chemical symbols if
we blew up our DNA code to the size of
written letters it would look like this
now we don't fully understand the
information in
but what we do know is some pages in
this book about 1% of it
act like recipe pages for how to grow a
life form we call these pages genes to
grow a new life form these genes are
transformed into molecular machinery
called proteins which react with the
environment to create the form of an
organism for example you have a gene
which creates blood cells the point is
our flesh and blood all grows out of the
information in our DNA we begin as a
program and DNA can begin as nothing but
random symbols at first what matters is
that when DNA replicates itself or
splits into copies
tiny mistakes are made resulting in
mutations to the program like rolling
dice with a few of your genes each time
you divide this results in some changes
to the form of the offspring some good
some bad
all by accident for example more legs or
longer legs might help a bacterium swim
faster gathering more energy and
replicating more than others and that's
the source of the feedback loop which is
critical to any learning process life
evaluates each copy of DNA via the
number of offspring it ends up producing
the offspring who do well will survive
and take over thanks to their copies it
leads to a self propelling process of
improvement for example let's say
bacteria have genes in their DNA which
define their body size as well as swim
speed what's the best size and speed to
have well this is a search problem an
evolution figures this out by randomly
sprinkling copies in the space of
possibilities where each life-form can
be thought of as a point in the space
now imagine the success of each point or
life-form is measured by the height of
this surface or a number of offspring
over generations the successful points
will climb uphill to the optimal
configuration the other offspring as the
environmental conditions change life can
adapt its form over the generations by
constantly searching for improvements
and saving them as information in the
DNA and one critical behavior that
emerges from this process is
communication which is when we have a
connection between action and cents for
example eventually bacteria find
themselves in a crowded environment this
leads to a successful mutation which
causes bacteria to release a molecule
which they can also sense broadcasting
their presence to the environment which
nearby bacteria can smell this allows
bacteria as a whole to sense the total
population density in a region so they
can respond accordingly
a kind of hive mind emerges which can
estimate how many others are around and
the signaling strategy improves their
chance of survival
as unicellular life becomes a
multicellular life we also see this idea
of outward signaling turn inward to
coordinate a body of different parts
moving from external to internal
communication to make multicellular
bodies work it requires the parts of the
developing system to talk to each other
in order to coordinate actions such as
swimming or rapid reactions such as
snapping for example the Venus flytrap
it contains a series of sensitive hairs
which if touched cause it to clamp shut
to capture live insects the key point is
out of this evolutionary learning
process we see intelligence emerge as
hardwired form and function where fixed
behaviors are triggered by a fixed sense
but this wind up and go approach is
limiting as the life forms can adapt in
the short-term to changes within the
environment their behavior is locked in
for life this leads to the next layer of
learning we see grow out of the
evolutionary process in life learning
based on experience resulting in
behavior which adapts within a lifetime
this layer of learning is what we use
our brains for brains evolved in
organisms as bundles of signaling cells
that cluster together in groups to form
flexible control mechanisms allowing
connections between sense and action to
evolve within life the simplest example
of this kind of learning is habituation
for example some plants close up if they
are impacted as a form of protection
however if the harmless impact happens
over and over again such as drops of
rain they begin to ignore it but
eventually if you keep applying the same
touch without damaging it it can learn
to trust the touch - and we all do this
imagine again you are in the dark you're
going to Auto fear any new sensation at
first except what you learn to trust
it's the safest way to confront the
unknown when each step forward is a
mystery this simple mechanism of
habituation you can think of as a kind
of wire cutting or narrowing of your
behavioral triggers it helps to prevent
exhaustion by can
serving our energy on issues of survival
rather than environmental distractions
another kind of learning is the
expansion of triggers which is like
adding new wires or connections between
sense and action known as learning by
association the classic experiment to
demonstrate this mechanism was to
present dogs with the sound of a bell
right before feeding after a few
exposures the Bell would cause the dogs
to salivate even if no food was
presented this salivation behavior was
triggered by a sense the bell the dog
was not born to understand automatically
the experimenter created a connection in
the dog's brain through the experiment
the mechanism behind association is
rapid changes in chemical reward signals
in our brain such as dopamine which can
shape our pattern of behavior an
unexpected positive stimulus such as
food can trigger a burst of chemicals
which help positively reinforce the
connection to our senses especially
senses which are close in time to the
stimulus while an unexpected negative
stimulus such as getting shocked will
result in a decrease in dopamine which
will negatively reinforced the
connections to those senses instead
ignoring things habituation or paying
attention to new things association
allows the mind to shape our sense to
match our environment which enable
better predictions about how to behave
in the world this results in what you
can think of as an adaptive sense which
is the ability to change how a set of
behaviors are triggered and this helps
but it doesn't explain the active side
of things which is adapting our actions
to match the environment too to do this
evolution has found a clever strategy we
are born clumsy with a kind of
semi-finished or random wiring in our
brain only kind of knowing the shape of
what to do and to get better at things
we just add experience or play which are
random actions which fine-tune our
behavior or wiring until it feels right
this is what we commonly call trial and
error learning or reinforcement learning
where we try random things and learn
from what happens it's a form of
Association where the brain
a pattern of behavior leading up to a
stimulus and does more or less of that
behavior as a result the classic
experiment to show this mechanism is
teaching Birds or rats or octopuses to
push a button or pull a lever to get a
reward and this feedback loop between
behavior and stimulus can be very long
or very short some life-forms are able
to learn more complex or longer behavior
patterns and others it's important to
know that the engine of this kind of
reinforcement learning is experience and
that can be boosted by play play allows
animals to test out or simulate
behaviors without the consequences so
the key difference between evolutionary
learning and learning in life with a
brain is it allows learning at a faster
timescale and this leads to complex
learned behavior in life that genetics
alone wouldn't be able to provide in
advance and there is one more critical
layer of learning to consider and it
gets us closer to what we call human
only intelligence recently we discovered
a clue in our DNA which explains what
might have happened around 3 million
years ago a mutation occurred which
activated a gene called notch 2 NL which
extended the growth period of the brain
which led to brains which tripled in
size while other brains didn't so what
do these big brains do it's clear now
that among other things a new kind of
thought emerges a mental superpower we
all have it's the imagination allowing
us to learn with our thoughts what we
could call abstract learning it allows
us to imagine situations we haven't
experienced and gauge what will happen
so we can adapt our behavior accordingly
it's a faster and risk-free form of in
life learning but this form of learning
we know the least about brain imaging
studies gives us a hint of what's going
on at this abstract level we find that
when people are asked to imagine things
it fires an activation pattern in their
brain which reaches out of the sensor
motor regions into a new highly
connected upper layer of the mind which
is d-cup
from direct experience you can think of
this as our simulation layer and it's a
newer kind of thought from an
evolutionary perspective that we all
have and we can really see this
distinction between direct and abstract
and life learning when we turn back to
communication for example monkeys signal
each other to know that a Predator is
near
while bees will dance together to signal
the direction and amount of nearby food
and this is the basis of language
language allows minds to synchronize but
it's human language which jumps out is
very different when we share symbols or
gestures to communicate we do it in much
longer sequences than animals
animals tend to say a fixed set of short
things no matter how hard we teach them
while humans just go on and on these
longer sequences allow us to share
arbitrary mental simulations or stories
allowing the mental simulation going on
in our mind to leap out into another
it's quite remarkable that humans can
utter some sounds and cause another mind
to learn something new with no action
taking place and the capacity for
language leads to huge advantages once
it begins to accumulate over generations
each mind holding the learning of
thousands of years passed leading to
what we call a culture of behaviors and
technologies of extraordinary complexity
far exceeding what any single human mind
could comprehend or develop on their own
this is why language has always been the
marker of higher level intelligence we
hope to find in space it's also why the
classical top-down view of a I was
always language first which led us to
the symbolic view where we program our
machines by telling them stories about
how to be smart and this approach was
limited by our own imaginations about
how we think we think and more
importantly how complex the world really
is and that's why the modern view is
instead bottom-up where we look at
intelligent action as a result of some
learning
process where the computer is given a
sense an ability to act and then we see
if it can learn to achieve goals we
provide so this learning process started
in our genes then rooted in our
experience and finally was set free in
our minds which leaves us with some
interesting questions what form should
our learning machines take and who or
what defines its goals
[Music]